in terms of like the balance sheet was
this something that uh you guys almost
have like a treasury policy right so
using michael saylor as an example he
talks about his business in terms of
they have a software business a business
intelligence uh you know product they go
out and their job is to build great
software sell it drive a healthy
financial performance uh in terms of
revenue and profitability for that they
also have a second strategy which is
their treasury strategy which is
obviously all the bitcoin stuff is that
how you look at what you guys are doing
in terms of hey we've got the all out
parking lots uh kind of as a core
business and service we're going to go
out we're going to drive top line
revenue we're going to drive
profitability but then we also have a
treasury service or do you have some
other way that you kind of look at it
from a framework standpoint uh you just
said it correctly there so we have our p
l strategy right we're out there every
day paving parking lots pouring concrete
line striping
um and then we have our balance sheet
strategy and so uh so we're uh taking
those cash flows those profits um and uh
and going ahead and plugging them into
bitcoin
got it and then in terms of the
employees themselves uh i don't know how
aware they are that you guys are doing
this uh have you sat down and like told
them what bitcoin is are they asking
questions just talking about like what
the employee's uh kind of reaction as
you guys started to do this was uh so
what we did was we implemented a weekly
bitcoin bonus um i i feel very strongly
about this and so i wanted everybody in
the company to be able to
adopt bitcoin and so
when strike came out with the
pay me a bitcoin feature um it made it
pretty simple for businesses right you
have your uh they give you a routing
number an account number and um you put
that in we use adp for our payroll you
put that in through adp and so um so
it's just a five dollar bonus weekly
everybody in the company gets it there's
nothing that's taken out of their
paycheck or anything it's just a benefit
that the company is offering and so our
hope is that um you know they're going
to learn more about it i've i've taught
them uh some about it but of course you
always learn more once you have some you
have some skin in the game and you tend
to look into it more and so uh so it's
funny you know i was walking through
uh the shop after we did it recently and
you know guys are talking oh bitcoins up
today or you know bitcoins down today
this is what's going on and so uh you
can tell they're paying attention and uh
we're trying to get the message across
that we want um everybody to be able to
you know work work real hard here you
know they they come out they bust their
ass and we want them to have you know
savings at the end of the day and um you
know it's it's early in the process it's
early in the case study so they're just
seeing it now but um i'm hoping they're
looking back shortly and saying hey you
know what my employer was actually
looking out for me and those guys are
trying to take care of me i love the uh
the bitcoin weekly bonus i i think
that's a great idea and it doesn't even
have to be a ton of money right it's
just the act of kind of hey i'm going to
help you dollar cost average to get
started do you know whether uh any of
the employees after you've kind of
implemented this have started to
actually uh convert some of the other
part of their paycheck into bitcoin or
any insights in terms of other actions
that employees have taken so far yes so
um
you know that's my hope is that they see
the five dollars now they see it
appreciating value and they continue to
want to put more of their paycheck in
there but um yes several employees have
put their own money into bitcoin you
know they've asked me hey you know uh
where else can i you know where else can
i buy it i just said you know use the
strike app right there and you can uh
link that to your bank account and
purchase and um so several employees
already have and i'm sure more will to
come here yeah it's uh it's fantastic
when you create uh not only one uh the
environment where they see you doing it
two is then you say hey look i'll help
you get kind of jump started and then
you're basically just unleashing them to
the world right and let them go get
educated let them go figure out what
they want to do my last question before
my brothers ask you a couple questions
is what about other entrepreneurs
whether they're people that you guys do
business with their customers or service
providers other people in the local
community have you had any conversations
with them or any inquiries ask people
here that you guys are doing this stuff
i have so i've presented to my vistage
group which is a ceo group um and uh you
know i've successfully orange pilled uh
two of the guys and they were pretty
much the two that were giving me um the
most pushback when i presented so that
was really cool um and i just did that
recently um that was last month so we'll
see how it goes here moving forward but
um but i am you know actively discussing
it with uh with my ceo group and then
i'm also in another mastermind group
i've been speaking uh to them about it
as well and so uh just trying to get
everybody on board here because i uh for
me my passion is entrepreneurship and i
hate to see these entrepreneurs working
so hard um and uh and to see that their
businesses kind of get devalued like
that um it just frustrates me so i want
to help them as much as possible and i
think this is the best route yeah i love
this in terms of one you do it yourself
you got skin in the game two then you
turn around you try to help your
employees and then three is you then
turn around and say hey fellow
entrepreneurs in the local area right
let me let me explain to you what i'm
doing uh it's very similar to what we've
seen other companies do uh where they
basically say listen um i i remember the
the uh kind of infamous exchange now
where elon musk basically tweeted
michael steeler responded elon was like
hey you know what do you know basically
or whatever he said and my goal is like
well i spent you know hundreds or
thousands of hours studying this and
then i put billions of dollars in there
and elon was kind of like all right
maybe we maybe maybe i should figure out
more about this right so the skin in the
game is uh is really important